gauthier que vaut cette information des
russes qui affirme donc maintenant se
concentrer sur le donbass est ce que
c'est un tournant
écoutez on va bien voir mais ce que dit
gulliver est très intéressant puisque si
les officiels russes s'adapte en quelque
sorte ou en terrine la réalité du
terrain c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas
réjouissantes pour eux notamment en ce
qui concerne kiev et l'ouest du pays
alors se concentrer sur le dôme bas
c'est intéressant ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que le dôme bas ce n'est pas
encore acquis aux russes contrairement à
la propagande russe officielle qui dit
que le john bass est une région
farouchement arrimé à la russie que ses
habitants veulent se libérer du joug
ukrainiens si elle n'est pas encore
cette région libérée ça veut dire donc
les choses là aussi ne marche pas comme
prévu et que ça nous le savons par par
noro porter par des témoignages les
russophones du donbass contrairement à
la digue ou découpage et nico
linguistique auquel veut procéder
vladmir poutine ne sont pas tous pro
russe et on l'est on les voit dans les
combats on les voit aussi dans toutes
ces images que nous montrons ou des
personnes par exemple qui ont été quand
qui ont subi un bombardement et qui sont
blessés en quelle langue s'exprime-t-il
pour dénoncer les mener de la dîmière
poutine dans la langue de vladimir
poutine en russie donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a probablement là aussi qu'un
problème mais regardez la conséquence de
ce que cela peut signifier si on part du
principe que les russes veulent
se rabattre en quelque sorte sur le dos
de base est ce que ça veut dire que l'on
va assister à un maquillage un enfumage
de la part de vladimir poutine qui va
dire mais vous voyez moi je veux
protéger les populations civiles je ne
veux pas envahir kiev parce que ça
serait une catastrophe humanitaire est
la conséquence de sa sé nou pa l'ouest
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire on va être
peut-être être quand je dis nous je te
dire les politiques et même les
chercheurs ou les observateurs on va
dire on est tellement soulagée tellement
soulagé que la guerre cesse si c'était
le cas c'est pas tout de suite mais
c'est que la guerre cesse que finalement
on entérinerait là aussi l'action des
russes de vladimir poutine qui découvre
l ukraine il dirait et nous on dirait
bon allez nous donne bah c'est pas si
grave et on en reste là c'est ça le
danger aussi c'est que nous soyons à
nouveau piéger par nos propres lignes
rouges que nous ne respectons pas et qui
entérinerait certes évidemment personne
ne peut ne peut se se priver de la joie
de voir les combats arrêtés mais en même
temps c'est une défaite énorme pour ce à
quoi les ukrainiens croit et ce pour
quoi nous sommes l'occident pardon est
censé les soutenir hamon sur le nombre
de russes les russes disent qu'il ya eu
donc
1351 mort donc du côté de leurs soldats
on a appris aujourd'hui 1 selon les
ukrainiens en tout cas encore un autre
général venait d'être tué côté ukrainien
alors est ce que ces chiffres font
partie de la propagande gauthier a
priori les morts seraient plus nombreux
côté russe oui alors les morts sont plus
nombreux si on croit les évaluations
ukrainienne on serait autour de 16 mille
soldats russes ce n'est peut-être pas
forcément le cas parce que vous savez
que quand on par exemple quand on
bombarde un char d'assaut
le principe est de considérer qu'il ya
quatre personnes à l'intérieur donc on
dit voilà quatre personnes sont mortes
en réalité ça peut être deux donc vous
voyez que le chiffre peut être gonflé de
cette manière là mais en revanche vous
savez vous souvenez qu'il ya trois jours
une journaliste du journal komsomolskaïa
pravda qui donne un journal russe tout à
fait pro poutine avait signalé le
chiffre avait affirmé que neuf mille six
cents et quelques soldats russes étaient
morts et tout de suite son information a
été retiré parce qu'on a dit c'est une
erreur le site a été piraté en réalité
cette journaliste tenait son information
d'un membre du ministère de la défense
russe alors évidemment donc elle ne l'a
pas inventé simplement c'était
probablement un chiffre qu'on lui a
donnée comme on dit dans notre jargon
off c'est à dire en lui demandant de ne
pas le publier mais elle l'a publié
c'est largement minimisé oui c'est
largement minimisé mais ce chiffre est
pas loin de la réalité dans la mesure où
il provient d'un organe de
l'administration russe qui n'a aucun
intérêt évidemment à augmenter
artificiellement ou en réalité le nombre
de mots russes donc on n'est pas loin de
la vérité
vexé 9600 très probablement merci
beaucoup gauthier